so Justin we just saw the Microsoft
gamescom press conference and I guess
the big takeaway that everyone is
talking about right now is this whole
exclusive deal that they have would rise
of the Tomb Raider coming holiday 2015
exclusively to xbox it was actually so
frustrating listening to the Microsoft
press conference because of the how much
they throw around the word exclusive and
you just had to try to decipher like
does this mean is that is that actually
exclusive or do you mean exclusive for
this month and rising the tomb raider is
one that's come up over and over again
because they mean they seem to say very
explicitly this is exclusive to xbox and
not xbox one xbox 360 and xbox one I
would assume the word very careful with
their waiting on this and I think
crystal dynamics basically repeated the
exact same wording on their own blog
where they say so exclusive to Xbox
holiday 2015 so do you think and you
know they have said it is exclusive do
you think it is actually exclusive for
all time are we talking time exclusive
here what do you think no there's no way
this is exclusive for all time not only
does that incredible carefulness with
the way that they ward it always saying
holiday 2015 exclusive to xbox that lets
them come back later and go no we meant
Holliday 2015 is exclusive Xbox so when
it comes out for playstation and pc they
don't have to say that they said
something wrong or different they were
just being very careful with the way
they worded it if it were only xbox one
maybe i could understand a little bit
more but the fact that they're going
last gen and courage n means that they
have a pretty wide development cycle
anyway this is going to come to
playstation 3 playstation 4 pc probably
not we you were vita you know at the end
of the day microsoft did this to sell
consoles right so do you think that you
know come holiday 2015 they'll achieve
that goal with this exclusivity or have
they sort of shot themselves in the foot
with this whole thing well the problem
is that i think people are too smart
they're too savvy to fall for this kind
of thing that people realize when you're
this careful with the way that you
weren't things it's not an actual
exclusive if this were an exclusive that
would be that would be an actual bomb
shuttle that would be huge that would
make people graduate to an xbox one and
that's what xbox really needs to do russ
what microsoft needs to do they need to
convert people who right now are going
over to playstation 4 who
you know used to be on xbox 360 and they
need to keep those people on that xbox
platform